In this exercise, you'll implement a rear view camera. It's not quite a rear
view mirror. Because left and right will not be reversed. Right now, the rear
view camera is just focused on the center of the model. The position and target
never change. Your job is to make the rear view camera actually look backwards.
Directly away from whatever the full screen camera is looking at. For its
position, use the same position as the forward camera. You'll probably need to
use the camera's look at method. As well as some vector three methods. At least
I did. I've set up the two view ports. The one tricky bit in the code is that
scissoring is implemented. A scissor box defines a part of the screen that you
want to clear. This is needed so that the rear view camera view port properly
clears its area on the screen, since it overlaps the larger view port. See the
code to see what I'm talking about.